o psol seja bem vindo a mais um vídeo e
hoje vou ensinar como fazer um avião que
voa entre 25 a 30 metros
estou fazer este projeto para participar
num concurso que nós de tudo estamos a
fazer entre nós
os participantes vão estar na descrição
em texto e vídeo e fui desafiado pelo
isso é fazer um projeto utilizando os
seguintes materiais espera ouvir eu não
tenho certeza se isso é ser ouvido mas
se não for é bastante parecido um garfo
de que os de super mesa de plástico uma
caixa de cartão de uma pasta de dentes e
cotonetes uma coisa que vocês têm que
fazer se desejarem fazer o projeto
também imprimir este tempo pleito que
vocês vão encontrar minha página do
facebook
depois tem que cortar assim tudo com
muito cuidado e usei com um x-ato de que
os que parece dos médicos é muito
importante que vocês corta em tudo nas
linhas não cortem mais nem menos por
qualquer coisa que vocês mudarem neste
projecto vai alterar depois é o
equilíbrio do avião no ar e isso está um
pouco atrasado porque morei um pouco de
organizar o meu projeto é isso é só o
fato de eu ter testado quatro aviões
diferente aqui é eu fui fazendo o
primeiro deu pois vi que não estava
muito bom então podia cair vou alterar
isso e talvez fique melhor
fui fazendo os quatro vezes até chegar a
isto o modelo agora vão usar uma mini
notifica e eu sei que nesta partida
muita gente não vai conseguir fazer mas
já tive que tirar acima para ficar 50
curvatura e essa curvatura eu fui ver a
internet como é que são as asas dos
aviões que o senado já sabe mas foi só
para confirmar e ver aquela que fica
melhor e vindo é um forma do garfo
consegui ver que o seu colar desta
maneira e depois cobrir com o cartão e
ficar com uma aerodinâmica muito boa que
embora muito vocês vão dizer ah mas boa
só 25 metros 30 metros não voa mais vai
para essas pessoas que estão a dizer
isso
só boas notícias e vou fazer um avião
telecomandado e mandei vir os
componentes e depois mais para frente
vocês vão encontrar coisas sendo
comandados no rio
não como carne telecomandados tanque
robôs braços mecânicos muita coisa que
vou fazer usando os mesmos componentes
porque o que é bom nisso é que nós
conseguimos montar um tempo jato e usar
os componentes todos para fazer outro
projeto completamente diferente
vocês podem ver aqui com os que usar
este material aqui do cartão que estava
naquele bairro onde eu vou pôr o cartão
eu posso usar só espero vida
só que eu fiz um avião com espera ouvir
só e outro com o cartão e realmente esta
coisa aqui da aerodinâmica essa
curvatura por cima faz toda a diferença
para aumentar o tempo de vôo que cortar
o chefe ficar tudo assim perfeitinho e
usei bastante qual é que em trecho de
ter usado outra cola e é como a gente
poderia usar à vontade como tamanho
cunha tintas
só que se não pintar meu avião porque a
última vez que o pintou uma coisa ter
ouvido pelo tio tudo então é pelo sim
pelo não desiste assim desta maneira que
ele só aí agora só para fortalecer um
pouco e vou usar estas partes que
sobraram porque depois das quedas eu o
avião vai ficar um pouco frágil cair
hoje corta aqui para acabar a asa fica
melhor assim aerodinâmica e o mais
importante por isso o cotonete na parte
da frente porque o avião vai embater
sempre cúbico
se não tiver nada vai quebrar sua logo
isso aconteceu no primeiro deu fugiu o
10 pro segunda passa uma versão e fez
toda a diferença
aí vou correr por mais dois golzinhos na
frente para aumentar a resistência e
vejam com o suporte para a existência
fazem maicon uma linha reta isso vai
ajudar bastante na durabilidade do avião
e claramente que este último não
agüentou bastante
aí está um pouco treinado muito mas
ficou assim no caso do estado uma parte
mas em comparação com os outros aviões
que eu lançava 56 vezes e este aqui é
muito muito tempo eu fiquei mais ou
menos aí uma hora andando eu e como pink
fita e altar pronto para outra aventura
é e não só chegamos no fim espero que
vocês tenham gostado e se quiserem ver
os outros participantes nos links gostar
de inscrição para verem
o que eu tiveram que inventar com os 4
materiais e é isso muito obrigado
pessoal até a próxima